we have this from the post millennial
man-made climate change has manufactured
consent driven by profit motive claims
climate science climate change
scientists who said the ipcc was set up
to look for Dangerous human-caused
climate change this is a controversial
interview John Stossel did they say
post-money reports once during uh once a
one Starling of the climate alarmism
Community turned skeptic Judith Curry
told John Stossel that the man-made
climate change narrative as a
manufactured consensus because
researchers found that they could make
money pushing it the video released on
Tuesday pointed out how some scientists
take aggressive attempts to hide data
that shows that climate change isn't a
crisis she said they do ugly things just
avoiding Freedom of Information after
quests trying to get Journal editors
fired
the origins go back to the UN
environmental program Curry said she
noted that some U.N officials were
motivated by anti-capitalism they hated
the oil companies and seized in the
climate change issue to move their
policies along she appointed the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change ipcc which was set up quote to
look for Dangerous human-caused climate
change and not focus on any benefits of
warming so I'll pause right there and
and my question then is if obviously a
lot of people are going to agree with
her I don't immediately agree with her
because I don't immediately agree with
any of these people I don't care if
they're the ipcc or otherwise
what was she saying that there are
benefits of climate change of man-made
global warming but also that it's
alarmism it's not a crisis as she's
saying it's not a crisis because there
are benefits in which case the
implication is it's actually happening
you get it
and I'm gonna need to hear that woman
okay she's saying that it's alarmism
because they can make money
and that they're not pointing out the
benefits of warming that sounds like
what she's saying is climate change is
real humans are causing it but the
reason that it's not a crisis is because
we benefit from it
she thinks the scientists are just being
too negative they're being too hard on
man-made that's what it sounds like
I mean I I tend to agree with you know
anything becomes a crisis if someone
realizes they can make money off of
offering you a solution right like all
the companies that have sprung up and
are able to be like you should buy our
product because it's no emissions or
it's recycled or whatever else even when
maybe actually producing that product in
the quote-unquote greenway this concept
of green washing is actually more
harmful to the environment or whatever
it's from I mean we hear the stories
about you put in wind farms or fields of
solar panels and you're actually killing
everything that lives naturally in that
field but does it matter like are we
saying that's not worth it
um but it's hard to know exactly what
her Christmas is I don't know of any
benefits of global warming but I also
plants grow faster I guess
I feel like
I don't know it's nicer in the summer we
can we can reclaim Antarctica yeah I
believe the Ice Age which is probably
pretty cool but I think if the planet
ever got hot enough to wear Antarctica
melted and we could reclaim it the the
equator would probably be uninhabitable
the Middle East would be gone you know
we'd be we'd be living on the on the
caps and there'd be a band in the center
of the earth that's too hot to live
there's that one of the Larson B ice
shelf I think broke off as Antarctic ice
shelf isn't that a TV show Larson B no
no there's a TV show where the equator
has become global warming has resulted
in the in the equator region the equator
region like around the planet being too
hot so there are southern hemisphere
people and Northern Hemisphere people
and it's very difficult to travel
between the two hemispheres because of
the heat in the middle but it reminds me
of like the
I think there's some Show on Netflix
recently like different fantasy novels
will have these concepts of like War
like kingdoms that are separated by some
place that's very difficult to cross
like maybe we've been predicting this
for a long time uh the thing about all
climate science and I'm happy to try and
protect the Earth or you know not import
non-native species into whatever take
steps to protect the environment that
you're living in it just seems like the
metrics behind climate science change a
lot like with the thing that we're
concerned about
changes like one time I came on here I
was like aren't we concerned about the
ozone layer and everyone was like no the
ozone layer was trendy but now it's over
like how do I keep up with knowing how
to protect the environment if the thing
that they're saying is the most pressing
pressing danger changes all the time big
problem with climate science it's like
if you had a thousand people taking a
poop and you're like at this rate we're
gonna have huge huge mounds of poop and
we're all gonna die make them stop
pooping we need less people and you're
like well what if we move the poop over
there and afterwards no well we hadn't
considered that we don't consider
mitigating factors we just look at the
cause and unmitigated result and we'll
project that number out for x amount of
years infinite amounts of years and
we'll tell you that 100 000 years this
will be the result they don't take into
account that we can pull the gases back
out of the atmosphere for instance which
would be like redisplacing the the waste
uh did that answer your question I don't
know I think so like like I I remember
taking an environmental science course
like an AP environmental science course
when I was in high school and it being
like the we talked about this the other
week but the light bulbs they're like
the new LED light bulbs are gonna change
the world and they're so important and
this that and the other but now I never
hear about the light bulbs now I hear
about ocean levels now also I think the
ocean levels are over because all the
billionaires bought their beach houses
which is evidenced by the Maui map and
also from what I knew about ice and
water and volume it all sort of works
out if the ice melts but again maybe I'm
wrong and I love these green
technologies for instance wind turbines
in Scotland they got rid of 15 million
trees they basically deforested them to
make way for wind farms so you have that
then you have the Cobalt and lithium
mines in Congo which are for electric
batteries for solar panels for cars and
they have to be replaced every year and
that causes tremendous uh pollution not
only that there's a lot of child slave
but there's about 20 000 child slaves
mining these for solar panels so I think
you know all the people these scientists
that preach about we need to push wind
turbines we need all these solar panel
knows it's very hypocritical because it
oftentimes these things actually cause
more environmental damage you know
deforesting entire natural habitats and
so I really think what this scientist
was saying it is being used for profit
to scare people and you know if this was
true if it really was the world's about
to explode from global warming why are
these billionaires going on 2 000
private jets to Davos for the world
economic Forum every single year so they
don't practice what they preach so it
can't be that bad if they're saying the
world's about to end yet they're still
on their vacation on their private jet
in their five different Mansions five
different Mansions aren't on my own
property right yeah
now they're going to come out and
they're going to say Maui was climate
change this proves it and we're all
going to be like why do you own 900
Acres on Maui if you think Maui's going
up inflamed because of climate change
when I was in LA in like 2009 I was so
freaked out by a lot of this climate
stuff and I would start screaming and
telling guys to pee in the sink because
I was like I'm tired of stop wasting
water we're in a drought and so I made a
YouTube video I was like PM that you're
a man pee in the sink don't waste water
looking back like was that gross or did
I do the right thing you pee in the sink
like hopefully you clean it after yeah
top and bottom toilets as some people
call them I guess and these
environmentalists it's a two-level
toilet where when you're going number
one you sit on the top which fills it up
and then when you go number two the
number one flushes the number two cool
people do not understand
so a lot of people don't get this
anybody who's owned an RV gets this when
you use the toilet there is a pool of
water in there that's a diluting human
waste concentrated you know in its
natural form these these hippies they're
they're they're well they're making a
sacrifice I got to tell you did you ever
get an unintended whiff
I've never used one of those toilets oh
yeah that's in yours you didn't use it
what do you mean your RV did you not
have toilet no you don't smell these
things in the RV when you drain them
that's what I meant did you ever you
never bothered you never use them okay
but uh uh these environmental toilets is
like you CL you stand on the top you
know you sit on the top and you fill it
up yourself
and then you sit down on the bottom and
there you go I'm just not that dedicated
to see hey look California's in a
drought yeah they've been in a dread I
don't know if they're still in a drought
but the drought comes and goes basically
the Southern California is a desert and
they're only surviving off of Colorado
River water for the most part so hey
there's these people who live down there
are like I shouldn't have to do this
everyone else should have to and it's
like dude they would have swimming pools
don't they so if there's such a drought
you know give up your swimming pool for
the summer well there were several
celebrities that were running their
Sprinklers and they would get fined so
they were just doing it anyway because
they can afford to pay the fine so why
should their lifestyle suffer yeah but
you guys should all start using you know
reusable pla or like the paper straws
because that will save the environment
and that's ridiculous because you go to
Starbucks you get a coffee it's in a
massive plastic cup and then you've got
the paper straw which is just you know
so hypocritical so it's just virtue
signaling at the end of the day because
how's that saving the planet if you're
still using a plastic that was because
they found that tortoise that giant
turtle with the straw stuck in his nose
did you ever see that video yeah and
they have like pliers trying to pull it
out it's bleeding I spent a lot of time
cutting up the like plastic rings for
soda cans because of those images of
like various things would swim through
don't get stuck it was super upsetting I
didn't like that at all but then you
know we don't talk about the fact that
you can order mixed wildflowers off of
Amazon and throw all this or like the
seeds of them all over your yard and
actually all of the plants are native to
China so you're actually hurting your
local biome because it's not clearly
marked but the environmentalist
environmentalists don't care about that
but they do care about like none of it
makes sense to me there doesn't seem to
be any consistency I learned recently
that dandelions are not native to North
America and they're actually not weeds
they're considered medicinal and food
and they were brought here intentionally
and now they're weeds oh wow we should
eat we should start eating those yeah
there's like there's like a short season
for it honestly it's like a couple weeks
where the dandelions are all out
everywhere and then what they would do
is that when they were bright and yellow
they would fry them yeah it's like it's
like a West Virginia delicacy I love the
movement towards uh people will grow
native plants instead if you have like a
big yard instead of having just grass
you you grow native plants so you can
have native pollinators I think that's
sort of this idea of the tract home and
the probably UK has an equivalent of
this that our bill and at the time they
were a symbol of prosperity and you're
you can own your own home and that's
great but they all had to have the exact
same lawn and there's no sort of a
maintenance and there's sort of a an
aesthetic a purpose to it turned us away
from being part of our environment
here's what's crazy
we have a ridiculous amount of fruit on
the property bangs I've never even heard
of Greenbrier
I have no idea what that is and uh you
know I I go out by the shed and there's
this these vines with these like little
bushels of like berries hanging from the
tree and I'm like what is this so I have
this app called picture this scan it and
then it says this is Greenbrier an
edible Blackberry I was like how come
I've never gone to the grocery store and
grabbed a thing it's like oh it's
blueberries raspberries strawberries and
mostly due to uh like uh sturdiness of
the of the fruit so pawpaw for instance
why don't we why can't you buy Papa in
the grocery store why because it's very
hard to cultivate it's very hard to
pollinate it becomes very delicate and
it rots really quick so most people
never heard of pawpaw
then we've got uh like everyone knows
mulberries because there's a song about
it but how many people have actually had
Mulberry you if you have a mulberry tree
you'll have mulberries in the summer but
they're so delicate and they break
nobody harvests them and ships them out
even though there's like a tree produces
an ungodly amount of them it's weird how
people how the English how just humans
are like we have the blueberry and it's
like there's lots of berries that are
blue but that's the blueberry and
there's the Blackberry then there's the
orange like there's other fruits that
are orange but that's the orange orange
got its name like the color orange got
its name from the fruit oh interesting
yeah but and then I was just saying I
watched a grasshopper hop across the
lawn I was like a Grass Hopper he's
hopping on the grass like oh we're so
smart these humans like we're just so
brilliant the words come into existence
so like it's so childish
but peoples and people's names mean
things people used to name their kids
the equivalent of like Shining Light
they'd be like I will name my Chon
worships the Lord
Puritan name Trends those were fun like
my name means one who is like what is it
uh one who is judged by God and then
Daniel means one who is uh one who
honors God or might be the inverse but
quite literally back in the day there's
some dude who had a kid and it's like
what would you like to name your son one
who is judged by God but how did it
become going to Tim how did it how did
it that no that meant Timothy meant
judge Bible okay
I guess I used to like the Puritans uh
would name their kids like negative
things so that you would like remember
things you shouldn't be doing so they
have some really crazy names somebody
should look them up or I'll do it in a
second uh because we think of like oh
you know you might name your daughter
Grace because of God's grace or
something like that but they would say
their kids like just these things like
he who shouldn't sin or something like
that like these sort of heavy dark names
because they were trying to remind their
kids to stay like on the right path yeah
so you will look at Sorry God Tim Mateos
means honoring God
timateos honoring God that's where
Timothy comes from but my point is like
people literally used to just be very
direct with everything but my point
about the food is that people who live
in cities don't know what food is and
it's really fascinating when they come
out here and they're like did you plant
this I get asked that for every single
thing from like literally every time
someone who who's never lived out in the
middle of nowhere comes out and then
I'll be like hey look we have a bunch of
wine Berry I'm like what's wineberry and
I'm like well it's like a Chinese kind
of raspberry but did you plant this I'm
like I'm like dude there's eight
thousand uh brambles just everywhere and
you think like we went with seeds and we
planted all of them yeah and there and
the grapes are everywhere we've there's
there's hundreds of thousands of grapes
I'm not even kidding hundreds of
thousands all along this tree line and
people like did you plant them I'm like
that that grape vine is 20 feet in the
air where would I have planted that to
me I was thinking we should make wine
and I'm like you know the amount of
effort and work it would take to make
wine where we just go to the store and
spend 150 bucks on bottles of wine is
like so out of proportion right now that
I do think we're living in like this
luxurious society that can't sustain it
just can't like we should be
prioritizing The Grapes on the property
and making the wine it would be fun like
this idea of like the farm to table or
eat local movement is interesting the
problem is that people go to the grocery
store and the grocery stores don't stock
local produce then obviously it becomes
hard to eat the stuff like there there
is a challenge to it I think you know
when we had more Regional Food Systems
meaning that farmers ship their foods to
local grocery stores we probably had
more diversity in our diet which is
interesting and there was probably more
Regional Cuisine right like we're
talking about like stuff that's in West
Virginia if you probably went back and
found like an old West Virginia cookbook
they used things that were in the area
it was different and now we still have
sort of a homogeneous culture across the
U.S if you go to any grocery store you
expect to see a certain things
homogenization of the world and it's
horrifying like I've talked about how I
went to the Bahamas I went to Nassau and
I'm like this is going to be cool I'm
going to see some some local flavor and
I get off the boat and it's like Gucci
Hard Rock Cafe Starbucks and I'm just
like why okay I guess I got a Starbucks
down the street for me I need to come
here for this maybe that's the intention
maybe that's what they want but uh they
have this service where you can get
shipped exotic fruits and most people
don't even know what these things are
because you go to the grocery store and
there's like seven fruits you can buy
and then sometimes there's like a
prickly pear and people like ooh look at
this weird one and it's just like dude
there's so much crazy stuff going on we
have Blackberry black cherry trees the
black cherries are in season right now
so there's probably on One Tree or what
is there 200 000 black cherries just
crazy I don't even know how to get them
they're just like all the way in the top
40 feet in the air yeah we need like a
machine that you latch around the trunk
and then it just vibrates me up and they
all fall down have you seen that video
of like a truck that does it with
oranges uh but I think what you're
saying is probably because the idea that
things are in season like you can't get
them all the times and Americans
probably just all mod modern Western
culture we expect things now and we
don't want to have to wait like you can
get strawberries in the grocery store
all year round they have a growing
season we just grow them in greenhouses
no that's an innovation that's pretty
cool on the other hand what are we
missing out on because we've simplified
our minds to only expect to eat
strawberries this is why a lot of the
climate change stuff doesn't bother me
when they're like you shouldn't be
getting avocados in the winter and I'm
like yeah I I agree with that it's like
ridiculous that we grow avocados in
Mexico and then we ship them to New York
for a bunch of hipsters so they can have
their winter avocado toast like just
have the fruit and stuff that's
available in your region in these times
now I get it I get it in winter you need
to ship food in because they're not
growing this stuff but I just think
generally
I am I am slightly offended by Urban
liberals who are complaining about
climate change while being the primary
beneficiaries of of the you know the the
gas guzzling imperialism right right
it's like it's like dude it's you it's
not the dude who's got a bunch of
chickens in Appalachia who's eating
pawpaw and who's he's not getting pawpaw
shipped to him from Mexico and he's
preserving stuff so that in the winter
he'll have some type of fruit yeah we
made wineberry Jam exactly it's great we
saved it's still good it's a different
culture mulberry jam too right it's it's
a cultural difference of having to think
like I'm going to have to think ahead
I'm going to have to plan what I'm going
to eat in the winter so I have something
we're we're much more of an on-demand
Society now of course I benefit from
that I go to the grocery store like I
there are things that I enjoy in
modernity not having to prep food and
farm all Center and things like that on
the other hand like as a culture what
did we lose when we wanted the
convenience we lost the sense of
appreciation and value you know because
when we have a meal we don't appreciate
where has that come from you know who
picked that from the tree so I think
that's why it's nice to grow locally if
you can grow vegetables in your own
garden because you appreciate it and
also the taste is so much better you
know when you grow lettuce or potatoes
and you cook it it tastes beautiful
there's no no harmful chemicals on it
from Monsanto or anything it's just
purely out of the ground so I think
there's a there's something nice about
that appreciating and kind of going back
to you know old times when we used to
grow our own vegetables and you know
everybody if they have a little garden
just grow a few things I think that's a
nice thing do you think there's emotions
involved with vegetables like when you
the way you pick them because I know
with animals if you Slaughter an animal
that's in fear it'll produce a lot of
cortisol the meat won't be as good I've
heard that yeah I know that if I'm
stressed out and I eat food I have a
harder time digesting because I'm
stressed thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time